If you're lucky enough to date a girl who does Pilates or yoga,
you should marry her.
these girls are part of the elite,
high value women
instead of partying all night or on weekends
you know what she's doing?
she's doing her skincare and then hopping into bed early
because she knows that she has to wake up early just to get to her class
pilates and yoga might sound like cute
girly workouts
but they're definitely not for the weak
They’re doing hour long full body workouts, doing pulse squats for long durations,
core workouts,
doing planks to downward dogs,
crazy movements
and half the time they're not even breaking a sweat
but you may not think that these workout classes are hard,
but I've seen some of the strongest looking men not be able to keep up in class.
these women are flexible and usually in the best shape of their lives
Not only that, but they finish these workouts and are in a great mood
after getting all these natural endorphins
and then they're ready to tackle on the day like it's nothing
like they didn't just sweat for an hour and do an intense workout
These workouts are helping them relax and lower their stress hormones
Improves their energy and overall physical and mental wellness
They don't have the energy to go out and party
because they're putting in the energy to better themselves
and they're more likely to treat you better
because they're in a good mood after getting a workout in
so she's in great shape
she's less stressed out
she's generally happier
and she'll probably treat you better
why would you not marry her?